all right I think we're good to go
thank you so much for coming this is the
last session of the day I hope you've
all had a really great day of the best
conference in the world I think we
should give the the people organizing
this conference a really big applause
before we get started
perfect I'm not coming here I've
travelled all the way from Gothenburg in
Sweden people ask me how long the flight
was and if I'm jet-lagged I just love
the people outside of Scandinavia have
no idea how far it is between Sweden in
Norway another funny thing is that after
this talk because I'm from Scandinavia I
will probably be sunburned by these
lights so I'm going to turn up like a
shrimp tomorrow but that's fine so we're
gonna talk about c-sharp eight and
Beyond after this talk will all be
excellent f-sharp developers because we
all know that c-sharp is taking all the
best features from the best programming
languages and if we ask functional
programmers we all know that f-sharp is
the best programming language in the
world and c-sharp is taking a lot of
influences from these different
languages such as f-sharp Java Scala
Cullinan Swift what all joking aside
we're gonna go through the features that
have been coming to C sharp just quickly
look at two features from c-sharp 7
which will set the kind of the scene of
the features that are coming later on in
c-sharp as well as the ones that are now
introduced in c-sharp 8 as anyone here
tried c-sharp 8 in a live product
excellent so hopefully all of these cool
features will be the new teeth before we
get into that my name is Phillip Ekberg
you can ping me on Twitter if you have
any questions I've done a bunch of
online things like Pluralsight courses I
wrote a book and you know you can find
all that online if you want you ping me
on Twitter since it's really hard to see
you just throw something in my face if
you have any questions perfect so over
the years c-sharp has gotten a whole lot
of interesting features added to it
it all started almost two decades ago I
think the first version of c-sharp was
announced 19 years ago that's pretty
long ago right so for a language that
has been living for 19 years and are
still getting a lot of features I'm
conference talking about a language
getting updates after such a long time
and of course that applies to other
programming languages as well but
looking at the amount of features that
we've been getting in c-sharp over the
years it's really amazing
you know c-sharp 1 was released as a
competitor to Java and C++ as an
alternative to developers that wanted to
build something really excellent on the
Microsoft platform and then in the next
version of c-sharp regard sings like
generics which drastically changed the
way that we build software it changes
the way that we build our applications
in the way that we look at engineering
our solutions and then of course we got
things like a sink and a weight added
later on in c-sharp that's one of the
biggest features that word was
introduced on the previous versions of
the compilers now async in a way kind of
also changed the way that we look at
building our applications especially
when we're doing interact with web
applications or web api's we're doing
database calls so we're loading things
from disk as everyone worked with a sink
and a weight almost everyone so that's
great there's additions in c-sharp 8
that will make your life even better
when working with async in a way so
we'll get to that in a little moment and
of course c-sharp is also taking
influences from other things like sequel
and we have influences from C++ and Java
and a whole other bunch of different
programming languages so for developers
that want to build software with all the
the best practices c-sharp is one of
those places where you can pick and
choose the practices that you want to
work with and then just apply that in
your software now what's interesting is
that I mentioned that C in a sink and a
weight was introduced in c-sharp as the
final thing final big thing on the old
compilers now what they've done is that
they rewrote the compilers it's all open
source so you can go ahead and check the
language features statuses on github and
you can also participate in building
these features and I've made a
contribution to this I fixed a broken
link in github so I made this huge
contribution to the compilers feel
really proud that's why I have this
slide here joking is slide this here
lists all the features that they want to
get into to the language not only
c-sharp 8 but also C shop 9 and X and
whatever you want to call the next
person so what you can do is they can go
on here and you can talk to the line
which design team you can contribute in
terms of adding issues to what's in the
compiler what doesn't work for you but
you can also suggest changes to features
that you want to see in the language and
that's something that's changed the way
that they build the compilers now a lot
of these features that I'm going to talk
about so this here is the the c-sharp a
candidate list this lives on another
place and github because why would you
choose to put them on the same place so
this here lists all the champions they
they call it champions it's the pretty
much as the language features that they
want to add it's things like improving
pattern matching and not adding a whole
bunch of other things in c-sharp so
again you can go in here and you can
have discussions with language team or
other developers and some of these
issues have probably 300 comments so I
tend to avoid those because it just gets
too technical
so add some of the features that I'm
gonna show you I can show you live demos
in Visual Studio 2019 preview but some
of them unfortunately I didn't have the
time to build the compilers myself and
introduce all of these features and
they're not all done
and speaking of done when do we think
c-sharp 8 is going to come out we've
probably heard that it's gonna be a part
of Visual Studio 2019 right but Visual
Studio 2019 was released two months ago
and c-sharp 8 wasn't in there so c-sharp
8 is going to be released
according to github tracking off the
timing somewhere around 2080 I'm pretty
sure I won't be dealing c-sharp by then
if I am doing C sharp by 2080s it's
impressive but this is just based all
the things they want to get in there
right so get up is doing some magic to
calculate based on the cadence of their
work and the issues that are there
they're closing this is the the right
take title the features of language
interesting right but it is going to be
a part of Visual Studio 2019 and what's
interesting with c-sharp 8 it's the
first time they're introducing language
features that require you to you don't
be on a dotnet framework so everything
that we're gonna look at here is not
going to be be working in dotnet
framework that's because they need to be
undocked in core 3.0 to be able to
leverage c-sharp 8 and that's a bummer
but it is see they rolled forward
because I've been framework it's done
and everyone should just jump onto to
the next cool thing that's how we all do
it in software right we rewrite out
things just to to make our lives easier
so with that being said let's let's stop
looking at slides for a moment I have a
bunch of other features that I can't
show you but I've got some slides in
code we all know that we love to be in
PowerPoint so we'll we'll get back to
that later on
but right now I want to show you a few
things I'm not updating visuals to do
now that would be a terrible idea the
last time I gave a talk on c-sharp I
updated a visual studio the day before
guess how that talk went it didn't go
very well but the thing is the version I
was on I had updated a few weeks earlier
and had forgotten to run through my
demos and every time I did a curly
bracket the visual studio just crashed
it deadlocked
so that was worse I couldn't even do
anything so just to be on the safe side
I'm not going to be compiling anything I
could though but so the first thing I
want to show you is sexually not a
feature introduced in c-sharp aid it's
something that was introduced in c-sharp
7 and if you worked in other programming
languages before tuples has been
something that you probably occur been
working with cinnamon used toppled in
c-sharp excellent so it's a great way
for us to for instance construct a
little bit of a type that allows us to
in this case map these two values into a
new type that we have here which is a
tuple and now we can define a type of
like this here we've always been able to
stubbles right in C sharp and dotnet but
this is a nicer way of doing it
so what's - what we're doing here is
I'll be constructing this tuple it has
two fields on x and y field and then
we're just mapping hundred into X 200
into Y that's super simple so now if I
want to use this I can save our point
let me just change my language it's
equal to get point and now what happens
is that I can say point dot X and this
here now allows me to not zoom in it
allows me to use X on my topple here so
we've got this name thing here and it's
just instead of having to in this case
we're just looking at it like this it
just looks like a way for us to just
introduce a type without creating a
class what struct
it's a little bit more than that so this
is preparing for something really cool
that they were introducing in c-sharp
aid so the things they added to c-sharp
7 is just in preparation of making
things even better for c-sharp 8 and
that's kind of a common theme I think
across the different versions of c-sharp
and they proved that when they rewrote
everything using rosslyn in the new
compilers they're doing that as an open
source project people can contribute as
break but it also means that they can
have shorter iterations off when they're
releasing the compilers so it's pretty
much just a nougat package so you could
pull in the compiler into your projects
and make use of all the new language
features in your projects and that's
pretty much what happens with a knock
date to Visual Studio you might be
getting the new compiler of Rosslyn
which introduces new features just keep
that in mind so now with tuples we have
different ways of working with that of
course I can take my Topol here and say
I want to deconstruct this
deconstruction is another thing that
they also had to introduce with tuples
so it's taking this the the table we're
getting out of get point here it's
deconstructing that into two new fields
on a new tuple called point now what's
interesting here is that what's
happening is that it's going to take 100
put that into X it's going to then take
that out of this result and put the x
value into my new X field that I have
here what happens if we change this to Y
we have an unexpected bug right well in
this case it's very expected but the
problem here is that it's doing this
based on the positions right so it's
doing positional matching so it's taking
the 100 putting that into X and then
putting this value the first value in
the tupple into the first one that we're
deconstructing into so the x value is
now going to be the Y value so don't do
that so the way that we can can make
this little bit better is of course to
say well this is just a var var for
point and then we get the same way of
working with it but we don't have to
introduce this really stupid bugs we
have another way of deconstructing this
into two local variables so I can take
the topple and deconstruct that into
technical new local variables as well as
just making a little bit simple
and if you went to my talk last year I
talked a lot about the the changes from
C sharp six to two seven point three and
one of the common theme that you see
there is that they're trying to cut down
the amount of characters you write and
the same goes for the changes that are
coming in c-sharp aid less code more
impact on the software that we build I'm
not saying that this has a lot of impact
but it's certainly a few less characters
right so instead of having say int X one
named Y two Y one we have this variable
here all right so that's tuples out of
the way what they also introduced is
something called pattern matching has
anyone used pattern matching oh it's
about a third so that's great
pattern matching is a way for us to look
at a given type and then based on its
contract or its traits we can cast that
into the correct type and use that as a
local variable that sounds very complex
but if you look at our shape here so in
my application my shape can be either a
triangle or it could be a rectangle now
if I want to make sure that this is a
triangle what I would have to do is to
say well this is prior to c-sharp seven
right so if shape dot get type is equal
to type off triangle right so this this
is pretty nasty for a triangle is equal
to shape as triangle so we've all
probably written code like this right
but it's a little bit verbose so instead
of having to write this everywhere we
can introduce pattern matching to make
it easier for us to look at this type
and do even more things so if we just
get rid of that we kind of have the same
approach to this shape here but instead
we're using this switch so we're using a
concept that's already available in
c-sharp so we have this switch here and
I'm saying based on the shape that we
have here if it's a triangle the case is
a triangle I'm gonna cast that to my
local variable of T and then inside this
context I can now use everything that I
have available on my triangle so we have
three different sides and we might have
a a position or something on the screen
right and if it's a rectangle of course
I can use all the properties that I have
available on my rectangle and of course
they have to inherit from the same base
type as well
so that's pretty nifty but only using
the switch for this it looks pretty much
just ask for bows maybe we don't have
the cast we're checking the type and see
you in a little bit of magic but where
it becomes really powerful is where we
can say things like I want to capture
this triangle when the the a side is
equal to the B side and then we're
inside this block here and then of
course I can catch the triangle down
here
that wasn't matched to that particular
pattern doing this with the previous
approach would have been a lot more
verbose we'd have to check the type and
then we'd have to have an other if
statement and it just gets a little bit
nasty right so this was introduced in
c-sharp 7-7 as well so pattern matching
in c-sharp 7 is a very lightweight
version of what we really want pattern
matching to be pattern matching can be a
whole lot more than just what we see
here and this is where pattern matching
in tuples are gonna play together so if
you're going to look at c-sharp 8 we're
gonna see how this has changed they've
introduced something called recursive
patterns as well as something they call
the switch expressions so have a few
examples that I'm going to show you here
but the first one that I'm gonna show
you is my method here that's pretty much
using the same code that we looked at in
c-sharp 7 I'm gonna refactor this into
what could be potentially the code that
we have in c-sharp 8 so I have this
result variable here that I want to
populate with some description of my
[ __ ] what my shape is and I'm gonna
return that for my method called
refactor me now what I can do here is
that I can introduce something called a
switch expression a switch expression is
a way for me to use this switch as well
as an expression pretty much like an
expression body member and use those two
concepts together to construct my
pattern matching so that would be
something looking like this so we'd say
shape switch and then based off that we
can now have a bunch of expressions in
here to match our particular shape so we
could say when the triangle of T we can
do this
I can spell triangle so now what
happened is that I have my triangle here
so we have this switch expression I'm
using an expression to match this and
then this here is returning that string
so we could simply copy the string that
we have down here at the bottom from the
old version of our code and then we do
the same thing for our rectangle so we
don't have a whole lot of lesser
characters in here but it's starting to
look pretty good right so we got a whole
we got rid of the case we got a rid of
the break and it's looking a little bit
more compact I cannot like this approach
but where it becomes really interesting
is when we combine this with the power
of tuples so how would you compare
combine this with the power of tuples
you might ask well if we take a look at
another example I'm gonna minimize that
for a second and we have another example
here it's pretty much the same thing
right
based on my shape I'm running my switch
expression and say when the triangle is
said T as well as the sides are not
equal or when they are equal we'll
probably make more sense I'm gonna run
this code block here so that's what we
just saw right but with the addition of
using this same thing that you've
probably seen when using exception
filters so if you've done exception
filters so you use this same contract of
using the when keyword so now we can
combine this with it something called
the topple pattern which is a way for us
to use in a recursive pattern so the
first thing that we're looking at is is
this a triangle that's the first pattern
that we're matching against so we have
checking here here if it's a triangle
but then we have a topple construction
here which might look a little bit weird
but this here is using a concept known
as deconstruction if we have a look at
our triangle there's a method here
called deconstruct which allows us to
get an a b c and a point out of this
triangle so when we're deconstructing
this we can take our object and
deconstruct that into a tuple which
means that we can now combine our
turn of a triangle together with
something that we call a topple pattern
so what does this topple pattern really
mean well what happens here is that
we're telling this here that we are
required to have the variable of a very
role of b c as well as we need the point
but we don't care if we have the X
defined what probably makes more sense
is that we can say I don't really care
if we have a point or not
so the underscore here tells us that I
don't care if this triangle has a point
initialized I don't care if it is
initialized I don't care about any of
the values so using this on different
types of objects depending on the
contract of your object you can check on
multiple different things when it's
deconstructed it's not always though
that you have the ability of adding a
Deconstructor to the objects because
sometimes you don't own those domain
object or you don't own the package that
you're working with but this here gives
you a little bit of a power when using
the tupple if we do have this
deconstruction though we can use another
pattern called positional pattern which
is also one of these recursive patterns
so what I'm doing here is I'm
deconstructing my rectangle and I'm I'm
telling this pattern here to match on a
triangle where the first value that I
get out of my deconstruction is going to
be 0 the second value is going to be 0
and I don't really care about the last
one and then I'm capturing this
rectangle here it's a local variable of
our and I can use that within my
expression if I still want to now again
if we have a look at this here it's
deconstructing this into the width
hiding in our point here so basically
what we're saying is that I want a CRO
height and sira width rectangle where I
don't care if you've initialized the
point or not again that requires you to
have this
deconstruction or your object but what
we'll see later on is that more and more
types are going to get this out of the
box especially when we talk about things
like record types but let's not get
ahead of ourselves the next one is
something that they call property
pattern so in this case here we don't
have access to for instance introducing
one of these D constructors so instead
we say that I want to make sure that
this property has the value of 100
so we can now say that we first matched
that it's a rectangle and then we apply
a recursive pattern to say well we
require the width to be 100 and then
that's going to be captured here and
then of course if neither of these
patterns are matched we can have a
default rectangle and we can of course
also have a default pattern so instead
of using the default keyword we have an
underscore which is pretty much the same
thing that we were using in the Topol
deconstructions as well so that's
interesting that's a really nice
addition to pattern matching and it
makes it a lot more like how you do
pattern matching in for instance f-sharp
Scylla Courtland Swift and all other
programming languages that use these
kinds of of language features so I want
to show you another example of how we
can abuse this and how you probably
shouldn't do pattern matching but I've
seen this happening in different types
of applications especially if you do
doing mobile and you're working in car
plain it's really easy to just over use
pattern matching because it feels better
in this case here I have this method
called visibility Front bool the boolean
is nullable because we all know that
buildings can have 3 different values so
this case here I'm saying well based on
this state of our boolean if it's true
we're gonna just have the item as
visible if it's false it's gonna be
hidden if it's null it's gonna blink
just to annoy the users to tell the
developers to write better code all
right another more realistic example
would be in this case here where we
first set our shape out of an HTTP
response message we have our HTTP
response message and we have this switch
expression that's telling us based on
the message whenever we have the HTTP
status code of okay we're gonna extract
that shape out of the message otherwise
if it's not modified we're gonna get
that from our cache and in all of the
other cases we gonna throw exceptions so
this here is a more realistic example
that you might end up with in your
applications but it's all powered by the
the fact that we can now do pattern
matching in a better way in c-sharp so
that's one of the bigger features added
in c-sharp a probably one of the biggest
ones another one is something they call
ranges if you've ever done work in for
instance Python you probably you
probably ran into using ranges ranges is
simply a way for us
to express start and end in a common
manner so what I'm doing is that I'm
constructing something that a array of
numbers this here is a span of T has
anyone heard of span of T we used it
okay so half of you know what span of
T's so span of T is just a way for us to
represent a collection of data and
whenever we do operations on this
collection of data for instance slicing
it up or or cutting it from the end to
the start or making a copy of it we only
get a reference to those exact items
that we want that means there's no extra
allocations so you simply point you have
two pointers basically that point to
start and end and that's your your span
off of things so what happens here if I
want to slice this up I use this range
syntax to say well I want to slice my
data collection up and this doesn't give
me a copy of it it only gives me a
reference to those particular items with
a range of items what we're saying here
is that we're going to start from index
5 and go all the way to what this hat
syntax means that we're gonna start from
the end and go one backwards we could of
course also use that in the in the start
here to say I want to start from 10 from
the end whatever that would be and then
go to 2 1 from the end I have no idea
what happens if you do this actually
that would be interesting to start to
from the to start from the end and then
end at the start maybe it reverses who
knows probably doesn't so this range
syntax here allows us to define a more
common way of us to work with
collections of data where we're going to
grab especially if you grab certain
amounts of items right especially if
when I work with two-dimensional erase
this becomes really interesting and
again it doesn't give us a copy just
gives us a reference to those numbers or
those items we have another way of doing
this as well and we keeps a normal array
indexer to say I want to get a range of
numbers and the same thing really
happens so it slices off our it returns
a new or it returns those items as a new
span ephant and based off this range
here
the ranges here the numbers are actually
something that that's called in an index
and we can construct this index the same
way as we construct our range by defying
for instance that we have hacked five
here which is the fifth item from the
end and then we can combine this range
syntax if we have two indexes here so I
define first and last we will start for
from the end go to two from the end and
then we're going to construct this as a
range you simply have your index dot dot
index and that's going to give you a
range of data that's pretty cool
makes it easier for us to work with
collections of data which probably most
applications are doing all right the
next one is something that's called no
level reference types this feature is
something you have to opt into and you
can do it in multiple different ways so
we can either edit our project file to
say that we want to enable this feature
by setting nullable context options to
enable before you do that you probably
want to know what the future does right
we're getting to that we can also use
this this thing here to say knowable
enable or disable so why would you do
that if you enable this project slide
because when you enable this feature in
your project what's going to happen is
wherever it thinks that you might have a
null reference it's gonna give you a
warning and some of us have trait
warnings as errors which means that you
could potentially end up breaking your
build a whole lot more than you should
right so you can disable this on places
that you don't want to use it and you'll
see here that it it'll it'll change in
the application so it's now telling us
that you should probably shouldn't have
this question mark here but once I
remove this thing here the the warning
goes away because now this is an allowed
syntax so what I've done here is that
I've enabled this nullable reference
type thing a notable reference type is a
way for us to say that we have notable
references we all know that reference
types have always been knowable we've
always be able to Don string STR or
string X is equal to null but now we
don't want to do that anymore
because someone at the language team
finally understood that in producing
nulls in a language is a really bad idea
and I know someone else I read this few
years ago that someone made like a they
estimated how much money have gone into
fixing no reference exceptions as well
as how much of production has gone down
due to it and just caused a whole lot of
lost money for for people that kind of
sucks so what what this allows us to do
is to say well I want to be in charge of
when we can use nulls or not we've been
able to do knowable integers and
nullable ruled in sin whatever for a
long time that was introduced in c-sharp
too but that we can do it with reference
types as well
so what we do is that we say that
everything is true that's not all about
and when something can be no like like
we're in this case this string here can
be null if I don't want this to be null
I remove the question mark and what
happens now is that the constructor of
our type will now tell us you know this
this property is uninitialized and
you've told me that this shouldn't be
null so what we can do now is we can fix
this so we can of course send the name
into the constructor and then we can
initialize our our property and
everything's fine right but the problem
is now I changed the contract with my
entire application and more things are
going to break so let's allow nulls in
this case and go and fix the problem
elsewhere in the code wherever we use
this person right so we have this this
method here called insert or update it
takes a person this is a reference type
and I'm not worried about this being
null because I haven't declared that
person here can be null if I had we
would get a warning we're still getting
a warning because something else right
because in this case here we're
accessing the lines property of a value
that could potentially give us a null
reference exception and that's a little
bit problematic I have two ways of
solving this either we make sure that
person that name isn't initialized but
in some cases if that happens on
multiple different threads we might not
really be be sure that it's it's
initialized anyways right so
fix the problem but we might not want to
declare the name in here right so how do
we fix this without setting the value we
can of course you see here the no
conditional operator to say well don't
get the length but what we can also do
is that we can ensure that this isn't
null by introducing the bank so we can
say I'm I'm pretty sure this isn't gonna
be no and again if we were to say that
person here is null we would potentially
get a null reference exception again and
we can say well I promise this isn't no
it just starts to get ugly right I'm
gonna end up with banks everywhere so we
don't want that but we have the option
to fix the problem and find find box in
the applications before they reach
production I know there's a good blog
post by Johns key to did this in no time
and we found a heap of potential bugs
that guy writes perfect code so probably
wasn't bugging compiler so another
example of this is we have this person
repository it's telling us that whatever
I'm returning here to the right doesn't
match what we have to the left and
that's because what I'm saying here is
that I'm converting this person to know
so it's actually figuring out that I
have a null value here and that doesn't
match up with what I have here so I
could change that and one of theirs goes
away but I don't wanna do that
but instead I'm gonna promise that this
isn't null huh what happened now okay so
that's not good right this just shows
you that the the feature is good it's
gonna help us find bugs but we can still
break things if we abuse the compiler
and view and abuse these language
features we can still end up having
issues but enabling the nillable
reference types allows us to at least
find the potential bugs in the code that
we have and we can go ahead and check
for for things and make sure that either
we check well if person is null in this
case or person that name rather we can
do something about that maybe we want to
log that properly to the database maybe
we want to do something else you know we
can fix our problems so that's an
interesting feature that's finally being
added to c-sharp next up we have
something called using declarations now
if you look at this code here real
quickly
you'll notice that it looks a little bit
different from what you've seen before
when you sing using statements so
normally what happens is that we have
you saying we have these parentheses and
then we have the curly the Curly's you
know and if we want to do more you sings
then we have nested you sings it just
starts to look like an error in the
application and we're gills we can't of
course make it a little bit nicer but
you know now what they're doing is that
they're getting rid of all of that and
what we can do instead is that if we
just undo that in this case here what
we're doing is that we're just declaring
our clients here the HTTP client we have
this using thing here at the top so when
do they dispose of this well it actually
disposes when the method is is finishing
executing so at the bottom here if we
have a lot of other things happening
let's say that we have something
happening here and then something else
and then something else it would dispose
that at the end of the method so it's a
nice feature because most of the times
that's what we want and if we want to
scope our using blocks we can still use
the same approach that we did earlier
that's one of the things with the
language features that they are adding
they're not removing any ways of billing
Saffir previously like we can still use
the old approaches of pattern matching
when we check the types ourselves but
didn't get type and then comparing with
the type of using pattern matching is
just a way for us to be less verbose and
build better software and the same thing
here like we can use these features if
we want to and we can also not use them
if we don't want to another feature that
I can show you is static local functions
this is a totally over-engineered
example I have this local method here
which is now marked as static so why
would you mark your local methods as
static the interesting thing with local
functions is that they have their use
cases and they're good but they're also
capturing the context of your method
right if you act as a variable inside
your the method that it lives in it's
gonna capture that into whatever code is
generated and you might have a lot of
side effects marking this as static
means that it's totally isolated it
might not make sense to have it outside
of your method because you might be
conforming to some design guideline
you're not allowed to someone might
reject your pull request and be very mad
at you if you're not doing this is a
local function and this is a way for us
to avoid the side effects so you'll see
here that I'm trying to change my my
name here or even accessing the name and
if it's not static I won't be allowed to
because this here promises that my
over-engineer method is not having any
side effects if I remove this static
it's gonna have access to all the local
variables and I can have a whole lot of
side effects
now don't go mark everything as static
just because I said so but again be
cautious with the features you add right
so the final feature that I can show you
inside Visual Studio I promise you to
show you something cool with async and a
weight and an improvement - how do you
say sh Encana weight in c-sharp so in
this case here you'll see here that I
have my async pain method that's an
introduction in c-sharp 7 so you can
either do asynchronous console
applications but the change here from
from c-sharp 8 is that we can now have
the await keyword in front of our
foreach loop that means that we can work
with a stream of data so this here is
called asynchronous streams and
enumerables it means that imagine we are
retrieving data from either hardware or
we're retrieving data from the web and
it's coming in a little bit of a time
right so we want to manage the data once
we get it we're going to display the
data to the user as soon as they get
downloaded from either disk or or the
web or hardware right so how do we do
that well we had adviye weight keyword
inside of a foreach loop which now
indicates that this method here is going
to be a synchronous it's going to give
us chunks of data and as soon as they're
available we'll be back inside our body
of our for each loop and then it's going
to wait for the next one it's gonna wait
for the next one after that and then
when it's done it goes ahead and runs
the the next part of the code so what
does that implementation look like well
first of all we're using something
called the ia sync enumerable which is
the new thing so you have the async
keyword previously you had to do async
task now you have to do async enumerable
of T if you're doing an icing person
innumerable can it make sense if we
expand this we can see here I have a
normal for loop
just gonna loop from zero to ten I'm
using the yield return which means that
just return every item back to the
caller whenever it's available and then
I have some other over-engineered code
here basically what it's doing is that
it's waiting
300 milliseconds after that it's gonna
return the value back to the caller and
then it goes over again it's gonna do
that ten times now if I run this code
here hopefully still works we'll see her
that's going to stream out this to the
console and I'm printing this out inside
our main method inside the body of this
foreach loop right so that's pretty cool
so what about a more realistic example
let's say that I'm working with this
file here that I have on my file system
I'm loading some lyrics from disk I'm
again I'm using this using declaration
right so I'm saying here that I'm a load
is stream from disk then for each line
just a side note they want to make this
a little bit more pretty by changing
this to allow us to do that in line but
you can't do that now you have to
declare that on the on the line before
so what I'm doing now is that I'm a
synchronously reading a line for my file
we open up the lyrics file on my disk
just imagine it's a super large file
right I'm gonna read a line as long as
this line isn't no we're gonna return
that line to the caller and then just to
save some CPU cycles or whatever we're
gonna wait for 400 milliseconds right
does that make sense
cool all right I forgot to tell you like
I totally understand it's the last
session of the day if you fall asleep
try not to fall asleep to your neighbor
on your neighbor doesn't go very well
all right so now let's see if you know
what these lyrics are
Fleury rickrolled by C sharp 8 can I
almost race though that we can now load
these lines from our file we wait for
400 milliseconds and then we get their
next line then we get the next line and
we can work with streams of data it's a
really nice addition to the language
that sort that's all the language
feature that I can show you in Visual
Studio the next ones are going to be all
in PowerPoint because again I didn't
have time to build on myself so I did
mention earlier that it now requires
darknet Core 3.0 right and that's
because they want to add things like
target type new expressions they won't
experiment with changing the the
language runtime to allow us to
introduce new features and I think
that's good because being you know
restricted by just doing compiler magic
isn't really going to be sufficient if
we want to build a programming language
of the future because building software
now and compared to when c-sharp 1 was
released 19 years ago it's not the same
thing it's totally different now target
type new expressions it's a pretty small
feature instead of writing var triangle
is equal to new triangle we can ever say
triangle triangle is equal to new this
here I believe required a one time
change but what's interesting with this
is that in the case of a dictionary
we've all kind of hated to to create
instances of things like dictionaries or
things that are really long in this case
here it's just in first that this is
going to be a list of integers if we use
that in the nested context right so
that's pretty cool it just makes it a
little bit nicer when we write our code
I think it's a good addition now another
really small feature is default in
deconstruction so they're doing changes
and doing additions to deconstruction
and tuples in this case here we want to
create a default topple for this but why
would we say default default when we can
simply say is equal to T fault and just
figures it out but some of these things
they cannot do with compiler magic they
need to rely on changes in the runtime
how many of you had have are working in
versus web projects and are trying
- or have tried to do generic attributes
that's not just a few okay normally I
meet a lot of developers that try to do
generic attributes and one of the things
that they do is that they introduced his
constructor where they take the tie
because it can't do generic generic
attributes in c-sharp or at least well
you will be able to you otherwise why
would I show this slide so what you can
do now is that instead of having to do
that you can now simply have a custom
attribute of T and you can use that
generic type in the in your custom
attribute and the things this is a good
addition next up they're doing some
changes to to be allow us to skip
passing parameters especially in this
case here it's something called color
expression attribute so imagine in this
case here we have this method called
assert it takes a boolean called the
condition then we have an other
parameter called message we apply this
attribute called call argument
expression and we refer to the condition
parameter and this here when compiled
does now not require us to pass the
message itself because what it's going
to do it's going to decompile down to
something something look at this here
it's going to take the condition as a
string and pass that as the message so
if you're working with logging
frameworks we're rebuilding anything
like logging yourself this is going to
be really valuable or even if you're
throwing custom exceptions and you just
want to pass a little bit more
information this here is going to be
something that's probably interested now
the next feature here is called enhanced
using also known as duck typing I had a
talk to Matt's on the c-sharp team and
he told me that they might be scraping
this feature but the get up page is
still up there and if you've noticed I
have all of these links here at the
bottom to the you probably won't be able
to write that down but I'll share the
slides but the links here are to the
discussions on github and you can go
ahead and you can participate in the
discussions and this discussion is still
up there so I'm not sure I should
probably trust him right he's on the
language team but it's it's still there
so I'm gonna keep this in my slide here
because I really want this feature not
necessarily what they're doing in this
case here so what they're doing here is
we were looking at this this class here
or the representation of this class it
introduces this disposed method but we
don't have an implementation of I
disposable so why wouldn't I be able to
do using VAR resources equal to new
resource why not allow us to just figure
out that this has what matches this
contract this is a very small example of
that but imagine going even further no
longer having to explicitly implement
interfaces and allowing us to pass
passive objects into method that just
matches the methods that they were
expecting right I think it would be good
it's something that go has been doing
for a long time and it's it's something
that some developers don't like it I do
now the next feature is something called
default interface methods which is
really a feature that I'm scared of
coming to the language coming from a C++
background and having done multiple
inheritance before I think it's a really
bad idea to to introduce this type of
behavior in the applications so what
what happens here is that we have this
interface our work is on this I
authentication interface that allows us
to just authenticate something we pass
credentials we get a user back and it
that's great so someone can use this
interface they can implement their own
class for this and now I want to release
a new version a new get the users pull
this down and the application breaks but
they won't when they're using c-sharp 8
because in this case here I'm
introducing this expression here over
here which is now introducing a default
implementation for that method now
that's a very small default
implementation imagine this to be an
entire method with a lot of logic in it
we still have the same diamond problem
that you would with multiple inheritance
but at least now we can call
authenticate acing here because it's a
default implementation of the interface
it doesn't break when we pull in the
unity package and build our application
I know that people working on
open-source projects they really love
this because a lot of the feedback they
might be getting from their users is
that hey I brought in the nougat package
you broke my app well
it's an interesting feature to add now
the next one is no equalizing assignment
it's just an easier way for us to check
you for values no before assigning it so
instead of having to say well if X is
equal to null then initialize X with y
we can now say X question mark question
mark is equal to Y again it's about
saving characters right now this is all
if these are all the features in c-sharp
eight or potentially c-sharp eight we'll
get to where they might not be in
c-sharp baby in just a moment but they
also want to add relaxed ordering of
referent partial modifiers alternative
interpolated robots in strings and stack
a lock in esta context so next up after
c-sharp I should have written f-sharp
instead because it's all turning into a
functional programming language but they
might call it C sharp 10 or X or
whatever let's skip 9 like they did with
Windows I think that's a good plan
but honestly don't be sad if they [ __ ]
your language feature that you really
love they've done that to me in the past
I really wanted record types when they
rewrote the compilers they had a working
example of record types and then when
they released a new version of c-sharp
it wasn't in there because it's a really
hard thing to solve now further on what
they're working on c-sharp is things
like negated condition of statements so
they want to make improvements see the
way that we read hours offer right so we
want to read we want a more readable and
maintainable code so in this here isn't
purely readable especially not if
there's more conditions all right so
what we express ourselves with here is
well if the shape isn't a triangle right
why not make it a little bit more easy
on the eyes to say well if the shape is
not a triangle well do this or if not
shape is a triangle or unless shape is a
triangle clearly they haven't decided
which one to choose I would vote for the
first one because they don't have to
introduce any new keywords and I really
don't like the bang after if because
that's not readable either next one is
no conditional weight so what about if
you want to return something we want to
weight the task if it's not null if it's
not we just return that we would be able
to maybe just reuse the question mark
or the bang if it's really not null
let's not do that all right and we also
want to get record types now record
types again it's one of those features
that I've been wanting for a long time I
don't know about you but I really like
this feature so imagine we write this
boilerplate code all the time especially
when they wrote the compilers and
rewrote the compilers they've all said
they wanted this feature so they have
these contracts in their applications
where they write all the boilerplate
code we have this thing here it's a
triangle it inherits from some abstract
class we have these set of properties we
want the constructor we want the quality
checks and so forth we will just want
all of these standard things for our
data objects why not just allow us to
say well this is a record of a triangle
it has a slide a being C inherits from
shape would be great to be able to do
this but when you compile this in D
compiler code it wouldn't only be the
constructor setting those properties we
would get of course the constructor that
ensures us that this is immutable so
what happens now is that we have the
properties they can't be changed by
anyone they're set in the constructor we
also get the quality check but the
quality check is in fact checking the
values and not checking the references
and then of course we're getting
something called a method the width
width method which allows us to convert
this immutable object into a new type
with certain values so imagine we could
say give me my triangle with this side a
is equal to 100 then we'll give you a
new triangle so now we have two
triangles but you didn't manipulate the
old one and in a world where we do
concurrent programming that is super
important and then of course they also
introduced deconstruct by default now
the reason that they haven't done this
is because when it comes to inheritance
this is really hard so you might have
two immutable objects inheriting from
each other or we have one inheriting
from the other how do you make sure that
you can construct all of this code here
it becomes really hard but they're smart
enough so just sold it and of course I
showed you this earlier the Declaration
expressions so instead of having to
declare this this variable at the top we
can do it in line in our
Loup for instance again it's just to
make the code flow a little bit better
when we read it read it right they wanna
make changes to how we initialize or
create our dictionaries so in this case
here I'm just creating a basic
dictionary of a string and an integer
why not just allow us to do it in a
similar manner that we do in other
programming languages like Python for
instance where it can do something
similar to this here that comes nice now
there's one more feature that I want to
talk about and that's extension
everything so we can have extension
methods on known type so we can
introduce extension methods for lists of
things right that's how we got linked
and how we got all of those great things
into the programming language now
imagine I have this interface call a few
of T here this interface requires us to
have this T which would T called bar now
I want to extend the integer with this
so we could for instance say I have this
extension called int foo which is off
integer and it implements the interface
I few of int and then all of a sudden we
have this this implementation that
allows such say well I'm now extending
integers but how does this work what
what happens well I hope that wasn't a
staged falling down I'm gonna stand over
here so this here means that we can now
extend integers or extend anything in
the scope of wherever we have this in
our like if we have the namespace in our
application we'll be able to extend
everything in that app right so this
here would allow us to say well int X is
equal to 10 give us the the bar of X
that's totally confusing right but
sometimes especially the example that
they often give from the language team
is when working with math and
introducing common calculations and
whatnot on the primitive types and they
don't want to go in and add them
themselves in the framework they don't
want to add methods to integers some of
us might have very specific needs for an
integer and someone else might have a
different interest right we could of
course just create a class with a method
but
let's build something in the language
that makes it easier for us so I think
this could be interesting is just as
with extension methods changing the way
that we will look at things and being
able to change the the contract and the
way that we work with for instance
collections when we don't have access to
those implementations it's great I think
this is an interesting addition to the
language so they were also looking at
adding something called type classes I'm
not smart enough to explain that
especially not at this time of error
then they were introducing something
called read only struck members Parham
of span of tea and any sequel and or or
sequel assignment operators and if we
just look through the features that they
want to add to the language there's a
whole bunch of things they were gonna
guide right is anyone expecting all of
these to show up in c-sharp hey you're
all so pessimistic all right so we're
getting ranges right we're getting async
streams in enumerables and i bolded the
ones that i like the most
we're getting hopefully record types
target type new expressions default and
deconstruction generic attributes color
expression attribute enhance you sings
which is the duck typing default
interface methods why did I build that I
didn't like the feature notable
reference types no localizing
assignments switch expressions
declaration expressions dictionary
literals type classes and any sequel and
or sequel assignment operators static
local functions parents of span of T
read-only struct members negated
conditions if statements will collide no
condition lightweight and probably a few
more things so looking at this huge list
of features that they want to add to the
language I don't think that we're gonna
see all of them means T shar-pei I don't
think we're gonna see all of them in
c-sharp 9 maybe in c-sharp 10 but it
kind of gives us on D an idea of what
what the current language features that
they want to language is and it kind of
represents how we build software and the
way that it changes over the years as
well maybe they're gonna scrape half of
the features to make room for other ones
that maybe makes it easier for us to
work with salmon application so building
mobile apps with the link some some
faster parallel programming who knows
they're gonna add a whole bunch of
different things in the future that
makes sense at that particular time I
guess that's there there
big thing right finding what's relevant
now or what's relevant in 10 years
because it's certainly a programming
language that's gonna be sticking around
for for probably the next 10 15 20 years
probably not - 20 80 but it's gonna be
sticking around for a long time so
having a looked at a little bit of
c-sharp 7 there's been a huge amount of
changes from c-sharp 1 to C sharp 7.3
and now would C sharp 8 we're gonna see
a whole lot more features and it's gonna
make the way that we build software
hopefully a little bit more readable
depends on the developer of course you
can make interesting choices when you
build software but then again it's up to
you right so I hope you liked all of
these features if you didn't like
something my DMS on Twitter are open and
I hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference and have a good night you've
all reserved a really great night of
sleep and don't forget to vote on your
way out
it's been a pleasure being here I'm
Phillip Beckford
[Applause]